all right so let us revisit the example
from last lecture so we have a Markov
chain with two states 1 & 2 and this
Markov chain as a single recurrent class
right and then also it's not very thick
right because we have Sal transition of
this type so as a result this is well
defined and this steady state
probabilities from 1 to M in that case
for us M equals 2 right so let us write
this system and solve the system of
linear equation for this example here so
what we have is PI 1 equals PI 1 times
0.5 plus PI 2 times 0.2 so that's the
first equation the correspond to J
equals 1 now for J equals 2 pi 2 equals
PI 1 times 0.5 plus pi 2 times 0.8 so we
have a system of two equations with two
unknowns PI 1 and PI 2 let's rewrite
them can I pass this one on this side
and this one on this side so we get PI 1
times 1 minus 0.5 0.5 equals pi 2 times
0.2 and this 1 PI 2 times 1 minus 0.8 is
zero point 2 equals PI 1 times 0.5 I we
realize that these two happen to be the
same
so they are not enough to define a
unique solution so we have to add
another equations and we know that these
are probabilities so PI 1 plus PI 2 have
to be 1 and so now we're going to keep
one of these two let's say this one I'm
gonna write it here and we can rewrite
it by saying that PI 1 times 1 over 2
equals PI 2 times 1 over 5 so now we're
gonna take that replace PI 1 equals 2/5
of Pi to see the result of that and
we're gonna use that PI 1 and replace it
here so we end up by 2 times 2/5 plus 1
equals 1 which means that from here we
get that pi 2 equals 5 plus 2/7 so 5
over 7 and then we use that replace it
here and we end up adding PI 1 equals
2/5 times 5 7 equals 2 7 and we check 5
plus 2 equals 7 so these are real
probabilities so the priority that you
find yourself at state 1 at time 1
trillion will be approximately 2 over 7
the priority that you find yourself at
state 1 at time to trillions is again
approximately 2 over 7 so essentially
what we have here is the probability of
being in that state 1 settles in a
steady value that's what the
steady-state convergence means it's
convergence of probabilities not
convergence of the process itself again
the process will keep jumping back and
forth but the steady state priority will
settle to a given value here in 1 that
will be 2 over 7 and the steady state
priority in being in 2 will settle to 5
over 7 and finally in this example and
marginally when we have a single class
and no periodicity the initial state
does not matter